ONLY, OF COURSE, 23 WERE EVER
MADE.
JEDEDIAH?
JEDEDIAH: THANKS, WILL.
PARENTS ARE FEIGNING NEW WAYS TO
EXPRESS THEIR FRUSTRATION OVER
REMOTE LEARNING.
IN ARIZONA A NEW BILLBOARD
DEMANDS STUDENTS GET BACK TO THE
CLASSROOM READING, QUOTE, TEMPE
UNION HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT IS
FAILING OUR KIDS, OPEN OUR
SCHOOLS.
OUR NEXT GUEST HAS A TEENAGER
WITH AUTISM IN THE DISTRICT AND
SAYS HIS COMMUNITY JUST WANTS
WHAT IS BEST FOR THEIR CHILDREN.
JOHN LADD JOINS US NOW.
JOHN, THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH
US THIS MORNING.
SO, WHEN YOU SAW THAT BILLBOARD,
WHAT DID YOU THINK?
>> I WAS SHOCKED.
I COULDN’T BELIEVE THAT SOMEBODY
HAD, FIRST OF ALL, SPENT THE
MONEY TO DO IT AND THEN ALSO GOT
SO FRUSTRATED WITH THE LACK OF
COMMUNICATION AND THE PLAN THAT
THAT’S THE MEASURE THEY TOOK.
JEDEDIAH: DO YOU THINK IT WAS
EFFECTIVE IN ACTUALLY CHANGING
POLICY SEEING SOMETHING LIKE
THAT?
>> WELL, IT’S HARD TO SAY IF
IT’S A COINCIDENCE OR NOT.
BUT WITHIN 24 HOURS, OUR
SUPERINTENDENT WAS ADAMANT THAT
HE WANTED KIDS BACK IN SCHOOL.
AND WITHIN 48 HOURS WE ACTUALLY
HAD AN EMAIL FROM THE DISTRICT
STATING WE WILL BE IN PERSON ON
MARCH 15TH.
JEDEDIAH: WOW.
SO, MAYBE IN THAT EFFECT MAYBE
IT DIDN’T.
IT’S CERTAINLY QUITE A
BILLBOARD.
YOU KNOW, IT’S BEEN CHALLENGING
IN TEMPE.
IT’S GONE FROM VIRTUAL TO HYBRID
AND THEN THERE WAS A COVID
OUTBREAK AND THEN BACK TO
VIRTUAL.
THERE IS A STATEMENT FROM TEMPE
UNION HIGH SCHOOL FROM THE
DISTRICT.
WE WANT TO READ IT AND GET YOUR
RESPONSE TO IT.
IT SAYS BRINGING STUDENTS BACK
IS WHAT WE HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
AND PLANNING FOR THROUGHOUT THE
PANDEMIC.
WE CERTAINLY VALUE INPUT FROM
OUR FAMILIES, PARENT AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS, ULTIMATELY THIS
BILLBOARD SEEMS TO SEEK TO BE A
DIVISIVE DISTRACTION.
WE REMAIN 100 PERCENT FOCUSED ON
GETTING OUR STUDENTS BACK TO
SCHOOL SAFELY.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT
STATEMENT AS A PARENT?
>> WELL, OUR NEIGHBORING
DISTRICTS IN CHANDLER, GILBERT
MESA HAVE ALL BEEN IN SCHOOL THE
MAJORITY THE SCHOOL YEAR.
THEY HAVE SEEMED TO FIND A WAY
TO NAVIGATE IT AND GIVE PARENTS
THE OPTION OF BEING ONLINE OR IN
PERSON.
THAT’S ALL WE ARE REALLY LOOKING
FOR.
I THINK WE DESERVE THE SAME
OPTION IN OUR COMMUNITY AS OUR
NEIGHBORING COMMUNITY.
JEDEDIAH: YOUR SON IS A
SOPHOMORE.
HOW HAS HE DONE WITH THE REMOTE
LEARNING?
>> THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
CHALLENGES FOR SURE.
I KNOW I PROBABLY END UP CALLING
HIM SIX TO EIGHT TIMES A DAY TO
CHECK IN TO MAKE SURE EVERYTHING
IS OKAY.
A LOT OF TECHNOLOGY QUIRKS END
UP POPPING UP.
IS HE OVERALL EXCELLING IN THE
CLASSROOM.
IT HAS BEEN A LITTLE CHALLENGING
THOUGH TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT
HE IS STAYING ON TOP OF HIS
WORK.
MAKE SURE HE IS BEING ABLE TO BE
LOGGED INTO THE DEMOCRATS
CLASSES THERE IS A LOT OF STUFF
THAT GOES INTO THAT.
JEDEDIAH: I’M SURE YOU SPENT A
LOT OF TIME TALKING TO OTHER
PARENTS IN THE COMMUNITY.
IN GENERAL, DO YOU FEEL THAT
MOST PARENTS WANT THEIR KIDS
BACK IN SCHOOL?
ANY HESITATE STANCE?
WHAT IS THE GENERAL FEELING IN
YOUR COMMUNITY ABOUT RETURNING
TO SCHOOL IN PERSON.
>> THERE IS DEFINITELY A SPLIT.
THERE ARE PEOPLE BETTER STAYING
AT HOME FOR THE REST OF THE
YEAR.
THEY WANT TO DO THE ONLINE
THING.
AND THEN THERE IS A LARGE GROUP
THAT ARE SEEING THEIR KIDS
SUFFER.
SEEING THEIR KIDS FULLY
WITHDRAW.
I HAVE HAD FRIENDS THAT HAVE HAD
CHILDREN TRY TO SLIT THEIR WRIST
BECAUSE THEY WERE SO UNHAPPY.
THERE IS A LOT OF PARENT SAYING
THEIR KIDS ARE SHOWING GRADES
THAT THEY HAVE NEVER SEEN FROM
THEIR KIDS BEFORE GETTING D’S
AND F’S WHEN THEY WERE TYPICALLY
HONOR ROLL STUDENT.
THERE IS A DIVIDE ON THAT.
THAT’S WHY WE WANT THE OPTIONS.
WE WANT THE PEOPLE WHO FEEL THEY
NEED THEIR KID IN PERSON TO BE
SUCCESSFUL TO HAVE THAT OPTION
AND THEN, OF COURSE, THE PEOPLE
THAT FEEL THEY’RE SAFER AT HOME
GET THEM THE OPTION OF DOING
ONLINE LEARNING.
JEDEDIAH: YOU KNOW, JON, THAT’S
AN IMPORTANT POINT THAT YOU
BRING TO LIFE MUCH LIKE ADULTS
KIDS ARE DIFFERENT.
SOME LIFE IN DIFFERENT EBB
ENVIRONMENTS.
THIS HAS BEEN A CHALLENGE.
HOPEFULLY THE KIDS THAT GET BACK
TO SCHOOL CAN DO SO FOR THE KIDS